malad hamdulillah was salatu salam ala
rasoolullah sallallahu alayhi wasallam
thank you ramadan mubarak i have a short
message for you did you know how much is
spent 200 over 200 million this is just
what we know about the numbers are
probably much more 200-plus million is
spent creating hate promoting hatred of
Muslims American Muslims they're being
funded 200 million we have a shoestring
was called budget practically nothing
we're raising this awareness that we
have a campaign and we do once a year to
help cover many of the costs that go
into a media company a small one that we
have that's out there trying to relay
the purpose to people clear up the many
misconceptions so people can really get
to know who Muslims are the peace that
we promote the purpose that we live and
this open book that's for everybody the
car and get to know Muslims through it
read it pick it up we have a 1-800
number 66 to Islam if you have any
questions we'd like to continue this
work where is the support we say if
these people can be spending over two
hundred million dollars to bash Islam to
click create havoc in the world getting
people all scared of Muslims in Islam
when actually Muslims will be the first
to jump up and to help you to defend you
if you were in a jam you probably didn't
know that but that's what our religion
teaches that's what Muhammad Ali was
living he's a great modern-day example
and American Muslim hero and all of that
was motivated by what by him being a
Muslim following Islam not the Nation of
Islam says nothing to do with Islam but
what Malcolm X was upon before he got
assassinated and then Muhammad Ali left
these ways of division between black and
white because Islam promotes the unity
of black and white and all human beings
coming together solely to the worship of
one God just like Jesus Moses and all
the other messengers of the crater sent
they all talk submission
to the will of the crater that has an
earth-1 message one humanity one purpose
and that's to know your Creator love
your crater and to submit whole and
hardly to your crib these are the kind
of things we talked about I just got
excited I'm excited because I know if
they're spending this money to bash
Islam how much are you going to spend to
help share the message of Islam to help
share the message of purpose the message
of peace contribute to the campaign and
we'll see you next time every week new
show God willing in Charlotte till then
peace be with you